you can't yeah explain that you cannot
well thank goodness it's not too hot
right
right right right what is this um it's
alisab yeah yes and it's cool today so
amazing it's amazing how you feeling i
feel good i feel good yeah season 19
we're about to get going right 18 18.
oh please
she's like
there must be a season 19 coming up
oh please oh my goodness can we pray
together i'm just manifesting it
okay um who's your date tonight because
where's your where's your lovely husband
because you're here i'm presenting i
mean he's here you know we're trying to
be safe and minimal so he's here he's
home with the kids
yes hi babies if you're watching so so
kate walsh is returning correct yes all
right ted do tell me kate's amazing um
that's one of my favorite things about
the show right now is having
original cast members come back yeah
it's so fun and so nostalgic and we all
just have an incredible bond that's kind
of hard to describe and it's been a lot
of fun having everybody's idea come from
because i mean y'all blew us away last
season you know everybody every week
we're like
who's coming back in the dream now
yeah um well we had to work around covid
obviously and so we had to be creative
and think of ways to keep the show going
and still be safe and so the coma was
one
um
and then the beach and the dream
sequences was another and then of course
bringing back you know people who had
passed on to the other side i mean i
think it's just resonates with people
right everybody wants to have one last
conversation with someone they've lost
right so i thought it was really
poignant and moving the conspiracy
theorists will say this was kind of like
you know how basketball players have
their farewell tour when they're doing
the last season that's what the
conspiracy theorists will say well
they're they're not far off i mean i've
been trying to get away for years
i have been trying you ain't going
nowhere it's not because we're not going
anywhere trying um
i i
i have uh i have strong relationships at
the network and they have been very very
good to me
and incentivized me to stay and debbie
allen and i who i'm giving the
government
to tonight
creatively as long as there's something
to do
um
miraculously we keep coming up with ways
to
to have a reason to stay and so if if
there's a reason then that warrants it
so so are you really thinking this could
be your lassies i mean is that real
that's a real thought that that plays i
mean i'm not really supposed to say
anything about it so i don't you know
don't want to be disrespectful no people
i've promised things too so listen i'm
just gonna keep willing it now she's
back don't worry about it y'all it's
good we got her it's good
you